[Music]
rihanna delivers maximum heat during her
savagex fenty volume 3 show it was like
mind-blowing yeah those are pretty much
the only words we have after watching
the 33 33-year-old mogul's number during
her latest visual spectacle which
dropped friday on amazon prime video i'm
so excited and thrilled about
how we
elevated this year's show the routine
starts on rhee solo of course her
ensemble is from her latest lingerie
collection
it was perfect red lights are shining
bright as she lays seductively on a sofa
grooving to janet jackson and busta
rhymes is hit what's it gonna be
[Music]
dancers join the pop star for endless
hair flips and body rolls
[Music]
and we gotta give re-props for this
perfectly executed choreo
[Music]
and the barbados native gets extra
credit for dancing flawlessly in
lingerie no less a topic she opened up
to e.t about just days before the
special dropped what was it like doing
that you know that was some sexy
choreography
not easy in a corset let me just say
that much i mean but it is savage honey
i know how to make it work
fans of riri have been waiting patiently
for her to drop new music her last album
anti was released in 2016. so could this
sultry performance be a hint is that
your way of teasing the navy like oh
mama's about to return to the stage very
very soon how soon reid i do not want to
torment them or tease them guys i
promise
but
it's
it's my way of just being a part of my
show you know sometimes
maybe i won't do it every single time
but so far it's like i i like to be in
there a little bit you know rihanna is
just one of many stars featured in the
volume 3 show gigi hadid normani vanessa
hudgins erica badou nas ricky martin bia
and daddy yankee are just a few of the
big names re-enlisted to join the savage
x fenty party when it comes to booking
such a-list talent rihanna spilled her
technique
i like to go the professional realm okay
you know
so you know it's legit and they know
like i have a lot of respect for them as
an artist and their team and
the the rule the the protocol as it goes
people get excited to be a part of this
show and a lot of times they're calling
us now and it feels so great to
have a show that has that credibility
and that people value uh the stage um as
much as they would even a vmas i mean
people even pull out sometimes from
other shows to be a part of it so i feel
like if we keep pushing
ourselves and challenging our show year
after year like we could really we could
do wonders
[Music]